welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's here to
put some dirt in the eye of anyone who
thinks your boy toby maguire isn't
coming back for no way home they're all
the werewolf the internet has been full
of leaks for the last week and there's
been a brand new detail on earth in one
of the costumes that confirms a big
theory about the movie we're gonna be
breaking it all down but there's gonna
be major spoilers beyond what we've said
in the intro so check out now if you
haven't been keeping up with the leaks
and don't want anything from the film
ruined if you're still here thank you
for joining me now let's get into
spiderman no way home
okay so twitter account ember on main
dropped a lot of big leaks on the film
last week this included concept art for
the green goblins costume and several
scenes from an alternate first trailer
now alongside these we also got photos
of the three spider-man costumes that
will be used in the film this included
tom hollands toby mcguire's and also
andrew garfield's when i posted this a
lot of people said that it was fake
because of the belt on tom holland's
costume not being the same as it is in
the film however more photos have been
on earth and tom holland has 100 worn
this at some point now one thing that i
confirmed is that andrew garfield and
toby maguire will be wearing their
iconic costumes from their films however
going beyond that if we look at the
damage to toby's then it seems to cement
a theory about when the characters have
been pulled across
now the first bit of battle damage can
be seen on his shoulder which i've put a
circle around so you can see the
position of if we cut to harry osborne's
death in spider-man 3 then you'll see
that the damage here is exactly the same
going beyond that though if we look at
the glove we can also see that the
little finger is missing and in the
scene with sandman toby reaches out and
we can see that this has been removed on
his suit too so it seems like the movie
will potentially be pulling toby maguire
into the mcu almost immediately after
the events of spider-man 3. due to the
empire article last week we now know for
definite that thomas hayden church will
be reprising his role as sandman and it
is possible that the two are brought
across together at the exact same time
just looking at the leaks in general it
has been said that all of the villains
are going to be what-if versions of the
characters which explains how they
aren't dead as the majority of them were
killed in their respective movies
sandman wasn't though and we have seen
in the trailers that he actually seems
to be protecting spider-man at one point
from an electro blast because he didn't
die it is possible that the version we
see in the film won't be a what if one
and it will be the sandman who as we
know gets everywhere now though i think
it's possible that toby could be coming
across immediately after the battle in
spider-man 3 there are other ways that
they can do it that movie ends with
peter going to see mj and they somewhat
rekindle their romance i don't want to
rob your boy of that moment and there is
a way that they can still let this play
out now peter could be pulled close to
this moment and he might not have had
time to knit together a new costume
which is why it still has the damage on
it i really hope that this is the case
and that he's pulled across not too long
after the events of that film so we get
somewhat of a continuation of where we
last left him often when you jump ahead
with characters you normally find that
their lives have been ruined so that the
filmmakers have something interesting to
do with them in the movie i kind of hope
that isn't the case here though and then
he's just pulled across as he's already
been through so much and the damage does
seem consistent with that now the
costume designers could just be using
this for reference purposes but it is
interesting that they pulled out one
with the exact same battle damage from
spider-man 3 when there are so many
other options available that wouldn't
have it i think that until we see the
movie that this will be the closest we
actually get to seeing the three suits
together as vfx artist taran singh has
said that the three will not be
appearing in the new trailer it's been
rumored for a couple of weeks now that
the reason it's been delayed is because
sony want to show them on screen for the
teaser whereas marvel want to hold off
from announcing it it would be such a
big thing to experience in the cinema
and i've seen people say that it would
be like showing cap holding mania which
i kind of agree with taran has been
posting a lot of info from the trailers
ahead of time recently so he is quite a
good source and this may indeed be the
case but we won't know for definite
until the thing actually releases which
come on yeah do it do it soon the
movie's coming out very very soon anyway
that's a cool little bit of costume
detail and obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know as a thank you
you'll be entered into a competition on
the 30th of november in which we're
giving away three copies of zack
snyder's dc trilogy all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the green goblin's
costume which will be linked on screen
right now there's loads of cool little
details in it and we also talk about
some of the plot leaks so definitely go
ahead over there right after this if not
then you're a sum of a [ __ ] but thank
you for watching until the end of the
video i've been paul you've been the
best i'll see you on the next one take
care peace